you know I found this picture of you as
a kid and I show this picture I and
you're you're you're so gorgeous but I
was like oh this picture and I was like
when I first saw the picture I told my
segment producer that's not her that's a
boy wait a minute that's not Ralph
Macchio great in Karate Kid no but
that's a very unusual he has a very
short almost buzz cut he kind of hair
now what was going on there um I had
gone to a summer camp in the coolest
girl at summer camp had a buzz cut and
then I went home to New Jersey and I
wanted one of my mom took me to a salon
and they were like she wants to what and
they they did it then I showed up to
middle school like that like what's up
guys ready to hang and they were not
nice I had this when I was like Bob nice
I was like hi everybody
one day exactly I remember one time I
was shoved into a locker and they were
like um they shoved you into a locker
because they thought it was a boy yeah
and they and then I think I reacted and
they were like well would or you would
not see lesbian and this really helps to
me I was like well if I were enough he
lets me and I'd have to kill myself so
and then they
[Applause]
that didn't do me any like it didn't do
any better leave that did it get you out
of it that's a really good point let her
out of the locker that's just us further
you